thank you all I am so excited to be here
I have heard about this conference for
years and never thought I'd get asked to
speak so thank you all
um I'm going to talk about playing with
engineering which as Alex says is maybe
a little different than the usual talk
um
these two words don't always go together
um maybe they should go together more
both in industry and Academia hopefully
I can convince you of that my name is
Anne-Marie Thomas and I teach at the
University of St Thomas which I didn't
pick just because of the the only having
to write one word there
um
but in Minnesota not the islands but the
work I'm going to show is the work out
of my research lab and I run a fairly
unusual research lab at the University
typically we have about 25 to 30
research students on payroll none of
them are graduate students they're
undergraduates from about 12 different
majors and we we
play together this is some of the alums
and current students the work I show
it's theirs I I don't take the credit
for the good stuff that's all them
so let's look at these words what is
play and what is engineering has anyone
out there never used either of these
words in a sentence
right you've used them hopefully
definitely engineering I hope play but
have you ever tried to like actually
Define the two of them
like try this sometime try to Define
them I'm an academic so there's lots of
I let's do the literature review there
are still people writing papers about
both those words and what are they
um so we kind of know what it is but
they're a little nebulous sometimes
and maybe why should you a strange Luke
why should you even care what they are
and how they apply to each other
um I hope you do or it's going to be a
really long 43 minutes
um let me start with why I care
um and I I kept changing this talk the
more I watch other people's Keynotes and
other people's talks at strange Loops
past and it's like okay well I Gotta
Give a Little background here because
usually there's assumptions made of when
you hear someone's a professor so I'm
going to start with this picture I'm old
enough that we don't have cell phone
cameras
um this is me I won the kindergarten
best in the school science fair I grew
mold on bread it grew really well in my
dad's office he wasn't thrilled about
that
I show this because maybe there's an
assumption that this is the first of a
long string of awards for academics this
is the last academic award I think of my
life
like Fair assessment
um it goes downhill from a traditional
academic standpoint From This Moment In
like early 80s
um this is me in first grade and this
was a math assignment where we had to do
a histogram of everyone's pets in the
class and I remember making all the
little cutouts I probably spent more
time on the art part of it than the math
part of it that was the part that was
exciting to me
um so I followed that part
followed that part I I ended up going to
high school where I majored in painting
and acting and I had to figure out what
to do for college and I somehow
convinced myself that this was a true
statement this is the first line of my
college application essay I want to go
to MIT because I've always wanted to be
an actress and I stand by this as an
actress
thankfully I'm old enough that there
aren't a lot of videos of me performing
as an actress because there's a reason I
didn't get any scholarships to acting
school
um someone told me what to say how to
say it where to stand you know when to
stand and Engineering I thought in my 17
year old brain like this is a fine art
this is something I can go and be super
creative this is pre-internet I didn't
have a cell phone obviously so I was
shocked to get in but then when I got in
I memorized like every paper that came
to our house like do you remember mail
was an email and so I spent my summer
reading everything couldn't believe I
was going to the school was terrified
and then a thick packet came one day as
I was heading off to work at like the
ice cream parlor on the island I live on
and it was for freshmen coming to MIT
and you can probably imagine exactly
what it said right the cool welcome
letter from a club
um
this was like actually in text so
imagine the girl with pigtails who is
leaving her tiny Quaker High School
about to go to the school she's afraid
of and the students like they got my
address they sent this MIT certainly
lower standards for women
underrepresented minorities
the average woman at MIT is less
intelligent and ambitious than the
average man at MIT
so that was great there was no internet
I could check to see if other people
were upset I was like oh this is this is
see I knew they'd find out I didn't
belong here
um this of course this club doesn't
exist anymore they got in trouble but
the damage is done
um I went to MIT I found the second
smallest major the smallest major was
nuclear engineering and that seems
really dangerous for me to do with my
track record in math and everything else
um I became an ocean engineer I worked
an underwater robots and what I really
wanted to do was teach
um they didn't used to have teaching of
Engineering in K-12 back in the 80s and
90s so you need a PhD and I switched
coasts and I went to Caltech and I
worked on underwater propulsion based on
how jellyfish swim
but it was a really not great grad
student and Caltech was great they would
actually like show spreadsheets of where
people's grades were without names and
you could find your dot turns out
someone always has to be the dot
furthest to the left and that was pretty
much always me
um but I found happy spots where I would
you know I want to teach I'm going to
get this PhD in robotics so I was
running conferences for for middle
schoolers and doing things with art
galleries and kind of finding my purpose
and it started to kind of click
and then A really lovely friend who was
an admin pulled me aside and said you
know they were talking about you in one
of the offices and I'm like okay
she must not be a very good graduate
student if she's spending her time
playing with third graders
okay again I just told you what my
grades were this is probably a valid
statement
um but I did find a happy place I used
to sneak off at night to Art Center
College of design versus a student then
as a faculty member and actually even
got pulled into doing installation art
this is a
oh it's hard to see I think maybe you
can see it better but this was data from
the hector mine earthquake and sound
artist Steve Rhoden had this idea of
building a big sculpture that played the
earthquake on children's xylophones and
asked me to figure out how to do that
with basic stamps
um
I I've added this because if any of you
follow this this music and art Steve
passed away
um two weeks ago if you're not familiar
with his work I have a hunch those of
you who are at strangely would find
Steve rhoden's work fascinating but so I
spent my time at the art students and
the art faculty and actually I was so
nervous about my dissertation that I
invited all my art school friends to
come to my PhD dissertation at Caltech
and when it came to the open questions
you should have seen the looks on the
faces of my committee who were great but
they were not used to having
20 artists asking questions about a
mechanical engineering PhD
so I wanted to stick this here too
because play in engineering where am I
coming at this this number
is my grad school GPA I'm not proud of I
actually threw this in this morning and
they're like I have to drill this home
it's not because I didn't work hard I
was the kid who worked crazy hours and I
I couldn't find a way to succeed in
these systems
um it just I I get a test I panic
um if the pro if the class has projects
I got an A if the class was not Project
based it wasn't an A and it probably
wasn't a b but I point this out because
as a professor I'm very aware that the
grade students get
they is they take that as a value
judgment on themselves
um and maybe all of you were straight A
students uh tell me what that feels like
sometime but if you weren't a little
secret is
um
there's a great book called Amateur hour
College teaching in America
uh it turns out that most professors
especially in stem don't have any
training in pedagogy and assessment and
educational psychology so if someone
tells you that you're a failure because
you're literally failing their class
I I mean I could be right but I wouldn't
I wouldn't take that to heart too much
and it's taken me 20 years and lots of
therapy to understand that like maybe
that number isn't me
um so I moved to Minnesota I became an
engineering professor at a small school
uh near where my husband grew up
and eventually I also joined the
business school there and
this is my mission statement they sent
me to a really fancy like leadership
training and all the other faculty wrote
these lovely long glowing things about
learning and students and Futures I
missed the assignment somehow and this
was literally what I wrote and handed in
um it was I aspire to not mess up too
badly
um France like life goal
um and I can say I can give that this is
a talk I couldn't have given in my 20s
like late 40s like I can look back
you're like that all sucked but
we're gonna mess up and if we're doing
new things how do you not mess up so I
basically became the professor who was
trying to prove to herself as a
six-year-old that she could be an
engineer also
so what is play what is engineering what
does that look like if I'm doing
research what does that look like if I'm
teaching a class on Dynamics well first
of all that word we use that word a lot
play you could play Mozart you could
play chess you could play soccer you
could act in a play
you could play make-believe you could
play a house you could play with blocks
these have very different connotations
to me
um I I would argue that some of them
aren't playful so for the purpose of
this talk in my next 35 minutes we're in
this land
um we're gonna we're gonna talk about
this kind of play and there's four
things I want you to keep in mind and
I'll keep throwing them up there play is
about process not about outcome when I'm
in project manager mode that's a little
scary because I have to make sure I have
an outcome but if we're truly being
playful it is about process
think back to what you did when you were
a kid and you really felt playful
play involves freedom of choice if the
people doing it aren't making choices
they're really not playing
play is often social
um yes I know you can play things on
your own that fit these criteria for
today's talk we're going to focus on the
social it involves other people version
of play
and last play is joyful
and were you to walk through our Labs
process we use four elements in a
checklist is there Joy do people smile
is there Whimsy like if an ice cream
cone is Joy then an ice cream cone but
candy floss and sprinkles that's our
Whimsy
how do we involve new people that's
social and then where's the element of
surprise because surprise has lots of
great attributes including engagement it
changes how you think about things
so why does how does this look in a
class well it might be if you have to
teach Dynamics which is the study of
forces in motion you've probably swung
pendulums before what
does it look like instead of spinning a
pendulum in the basement you stick your
students on a flying trapeze with
sensors
um or what does it look like instead of
doing reference frame Transformations
you put them in a German wheel do some
motion capture and then analyze their
data you know renew harmonic oscillation
you could have a little spring or you
could take your students 40 feet up
bungee trapezes and then have them jump
um and then analyze that you also have
to befriend the University's lawyers in
the process
and you know the thing is like okay
where are you going with that well the
students are engaged they're smiling it
also led to some really cool research
you know this is a professional trapeze
artist that we worked on some sensors to
analyze her swing and there's some
hardcore engineering there that wouldn't
have happened had I not stuck the
sophomores on the the German wheel
okay well what else does it look like
you know where's Whimsy well it might
look like this this is not how I should
teach my daughter how to do this is not
how I would choose to teach my daughter
how to do a circuitry um so I years ago
wanted to come away to do this and what
we found was well instead of soldering
irons and and circuit boards what if we
create really conductive salty Plato and
what if we create sugary Play-Doh like
could we sculpt circuits and it it works
it turned into a company a squishy
circuits are used around the world now
my students have a company but once you
do that and if you're really truly
thinking process not outcome weird
things happen we were working with a
restaurant named alinea in Chicago and
through that we met a pastry chef who's
now one of my dearest friends and she
said well Emery the recipes for your
Play-Doh that conduct electricity
that's that's a recipe like literally
Emery that's a recipe like couldn't we
make a cake that conducts electricity or
plays music or explodes edible confetti
okay it can be simpler it doesn't have
to involve pastry chef I teach I've now
taught more than 80 semesters of the
Freshman engineering required design and
CAD class they have to do a final
project you could tell them on the
syllabus what it is or you could wait
and put them on a school bus the day you
launched the project not telling them
where they're going but telling them
what kind of shoes to wear and maybe the
bus is half full of preschoolers when
they get on because they're designing
for a museum and you were also giving
the preschool class the same assignment
right
again I I didn't actually realize until
writing this talk like the student I was
imagining I think the whole time was
this kid who was told that she wasn't
going to be good at math and science
and had horrible handwriting
um what would she do in class
so you have we have a great closing
keynote tomorrow
um right and this is this is we have
many great you know it's tomorrow but I
I had to throw this in because I've been
sent this cartoon many times and and
it's now a bad reprise it says this is
an interdisciplinary program in which
physics students try to hit psychology
students with pendulums and the caption
is my professors had an ongoing
competition to get the weirdest thing
taken seriously under the label
interdisciplinary program
I think I'd have a Fighting Chance in
that competition
um but that doesn't mean I would be
traditionally the best academic if you
ask the business professors maybe I'm
not a real business professor I'm an
engineer and as Engineers they think of
business we're not sure what I am but I
stick by these after 20 years of doing
this and so let's look at this and I
want to dive into three projects that I
thought really kind of to the ethos of
strange Loop
um plays about process not about outcome
that's scary and we can talk later about
how you how you get to products and make
sure that you have a safety net under
the trapezius play is joyful play
involves Freedom of Choice play is
social
so I love music when I went to college I
actually minored in music composition
and I was approached by a Twin Cities
acapella group
I should say when you're the professor
who works with circuses and Plato you
get really weird emails and it's
wonderful and this the men's acapella
group contus does anyone know contus
fabulous acapella group they reached out
and they said Emery like
what would you do with it like if you're
if our La if you guys and us play
together like what would that look like
so we had a meeting I showed up before
them to the coffee shop and made sure
that I wired up all of their spoons to
play music with the Makey Makey
um and that was our first intro and it
led to asking this oh man acapella group
at the time all of my coders were women
and we said all right like this is our
team what could we do with this and they
created A really lovely open source
playing around open source music
visualization process where you could
pick the colors and you could map them
to different things this is like early
days of it
oh this is a good test can you you're
not hearing anything are you
okay a sound I will keep talking but I
don't think this is properly hooked up
and you're gonna we're gonna want it
when we get to the videos for that third
project
let's see well yeah I mean this but so I
don't know how to fix it so if there's
someone who wants to jump up here and
fix it
well it's playing through my speakers
but
okay we'll do that for now trust me when
we get to the music videos that might
not be the best way to do it
um
okay
so we have to turn this back on guys
oh we tested all this earlier Okay so
let me just talk you through this part
you actually don't need to hear this but
but hopefully someone's helping figure
out for when we get to you know what the
third part is
um what if we have women's groups where
we match the color to the pitch and we
match the size of the bar to their
volume what does it look like if they
start singing about kaleidoscopes and we
do the same thing let's say pitch and
color but let's also talk about how if
they get louder maybe the kaleidoscopes
spin
okay and so this is a project we really
loved doing
um we did it with schools we had other
people using it
um but at the same time I'm also another
big project in our lab we usually have
many projects going thank you at once
one of our big projects was working at a
very different situation
um this is my favorite school I've been
collaborating with for 10 years it's
Metro deaf school so we've been working
with a school that's entirely
um birth through 20 deaf hard of hearing
deafblind kiddos and we've been running
engineering programs and camps there we
just finished a big coding project with
coding curriculum and getting ASL
interpretation but
those were two projects going on at the
same time
I didn't see a connection to them maybe
that's silly maybe you see that
connection but the best part of play
again is that I dive in and I just hope
that I find the right Playmates and some
of those Playmates were PBS's TV shows
scigirls and they came to me
and said well let's do an episode on
Cone and cords but for that episode what
if we have the kids learning how to code
be the deaf students and I did point out
that this is a music programming thing
and we said well let's go with it
any do you have any
any luck on sound
okay but it worked earlier
um okay well then why don't we keep
going and you know what this is actually
good because I'm going to show you
without sound then the scigirls a little
clip of this but think about my audience
it doesn't matter
um because we worked with their
producers to make sure that it was
hard-coded and hard captioned
oh shoot is this yeah okay you can just
read you're missing nothing
so play is about process and not knowing
what happens next
um and usually I would just turn off my
slides
but I know how Alex found me as a
keynote and there's a project that I
haven't teased yet that I really want to
I need you'll see I I need my sound so
we'll just Pat her here I brought cards
we do magic tricks let's see are we good
okay
I'm super nervous so I don't even know
where we were there we go
here we go okay so I'm looking at the
front row because you're watching and
I'm just nervous so I don't even know
how far did we get in this
earlier let's just go with this here we
go all right
[Music]
oh
Allah
[Music]
foreign
so that was unexpected I wouldn't have
put those things together but again I
invited the right people to play with
and that episode is beautiful it's hard
caption there's different voices for the
different folks I encourage you to watch
it PBS did a fabulous job but right this
is about process not about outcome we
trusted our process that we dove in
um you know the original thing for for
conscious we actually only had four
weeks from the the let's meet each other
and then let's do a concert for a couple
hundred people right and we figured out
as a team like what's the bare minimum
we could do and then let's go crazy also
um
right this is a lot of people involved
in this so This brings me to project two
of the three that I wanted to talk about
today
um I like coffee anyone else
okay I owe my longest like high profile
collaboration to coffee when I go to
expensive conferences and they have
fancy coffee like I always try to get
the last cup in before I go to the
airport because like be paid for it
um I went to a conference in 2017 and
the person in front of me was also
getting coffee and I figured out who
they were because they had spoken at the
conference and I gushed and said like I
am such a big fan of your work and they
asked me well what do you do and I'm
like I do I do education and I use your
stuff in classes and classes with
teachers and they said well we should do
a project together
um you may know the band um there was a
lead singer Damien koulash uh from okay
go if you don't know okigo's music
videos they are pretty Epic from Rube
Goldberg machines treadmill flying in
microgravity
um there's the slow motion long I can
I'm around for two days like I've got
them all in my laptop let me know I'll
show you all of them
um but they're amazing Science teaching
tools right like if you've watched these
they're incredible but the guys never
really thought of themselves as
something for a science classroom people
just figured it out themselves
so we decided to bring in teachers to
the room and to create something we call
okay go sandbox
and so less than a year after we met
them we were we were launching a website
with
tools that allow teachers this is
Damian's words to give teachers whatever
tools they need to connect the joy
wonder and fun in our videos to the
underlying Concepts that their students
are learning um what does that look like
it looks like making sure that
everything's classroom appropriate which
maybe isn't the first thing a band
thinks about in their YouTube page but
on Sandbox it's a page where you can go
to lessons not by standards you want
science class music class are we going
to explore sound and sensors I want to
show you one of the videos this is a
short version of one of the videos that
we did this one's exploring sound
really good a lot of things yeah
[Applause]
I should say Andy his degree is in
computer science
[Music]
all right and then we can map that to
science standards and art standards and
make it so that a teacher can use that
in a classroom
um it's September still barely
um so I have to show this picture
because again when you're playing you
don't know how things will happen and
worlds keep colliding
um September is international death
awareness month so the guys are signing
here
um that's okay go in American Sign
Language
so process not about outcome play is
joyful play involves freedom of choice
and play is social I should make a very
strong distinction here though that
play is these things if you are the
manager facilitating play you have to
spend a little time realizing those are
different things
um and you know don't tell a
kindergarten teacher oh your job must be
so much fun hopefully they enjoy it but
if you've ever had 35 year olds that you
needed to take care of for an entire day
like maybe fun isn't what they're aiming
for there and so sometimes as a manager
you're facilitating the play of other
people right this is the case of this I
work for the best Dean of engineering at
one point he said Emery just keep doing
all the fun stuff and I finally said you
know
I love my job it's empowering it's
rewarding but it's actually work like
there's there's method to this I'm
making sure other people play
so the pandemic hit
um Damien and Iris post actually be in
Denmark showing the stuff at a
conference and everything shuts down
um and actually
um the band put out a music video has
anyone seen the all together now music
video
okay so they did it in isolation
um if you heard the story actually
Damian and his family were quite ill
with covid very early on and they did
this lovely piece of music great video
you should watch it
um it was a fundraiser and the sandbox
team and Damian me the guy is my team we
all quickly mobilized and said how do
this is gonna be a while like how do we
use sandbox as a platform here
um how can we make learning playful even
though we're in a global crisis and kids
might not be going to school for another
year or two in person
um so the first thing we did was a lot
of people were had had remote choirs
popping up you probably saw lots of like
remote choir things lovely so the first
thing I did was I have a composed
composition student in my lab I put
Claire on it Claire arranged that new
song so that we could freely release the
music for choir and pieces great but
that's all free playful it's lovely I
love it totally worth doing but
okay go loves to do things a little
extra and so we had a chat we said well
what could we do as sandbox and up until
this point okay go sandbox had never
created music videos we were very
careful when we talk about it we create
content that goes with the music videos
their Okay go music videos and their
okigo sandbox education materials
but now things are getting messy and how
do we involve more people so the first
thought is well we can invite everyone
to play with us let's we can put the
music out and everyone could record it
and we could edit it really nicely
which probably would have been lovely
um but we also were like but what about
art and what about other things and
um we thought well what if we create a
video what do we create the first okay
go sandbox music video
um and do you think we could get people
to sign up to do this we don't know
um so our original goal Damian and I in
December 2020 we said do we think we
could get 2 500 people to sign up
because if we divide the video into
frames
maybe we should hire an animator let's
find a cool young animator let's hire
them let's divide it into frames we can
send them off we can import them in and
if we don't get 2500 people anne-marie's
kids know how to color and like we'll
figure this out
um
yeah so um we announced that at a
conference we were running and by
February we realized we had a really
awesome opportunity not a problem
um over 10 000 people and Counting we're
still signing up and we still had time
well there's no way we can make a
animated music video that makes sense
for a three-minute song with that many
frames you wouldn't see them so we
decided that we couldn't do a music
video we decided to write that in there
we're not doing a music video we're
gonna do five Wednesday I'm doing six
um and what we did was we took an
animation I'll show you if you could get
to see one at the end
um but we broke it into individual
frames and then we nailed the frames
around the world
um now we also though it's covet some
countries weren't even letting mail in
um so we were actually mailing we were
also doing digital things and my lab we
kind of jump in and figure we'll figure
it out it turns out if you want to do
seamless animation
from pictures that people took on their
phones and sent you from around the
world
um there's a lot of registration issues
my animator friends were aghast and then
they joined us I should also point out
I'm in the Twin Cities
um so we're working on these projects
around the time too that George Floyd
has killed
um you know the the the the gas station
on the corner of our campus is burning
um so there's a lot going on and my team
is undergrads and we're gonna figure
this out even though we're not in the
same place so we mail these all out
and it was beautiful you know some of
them didn't get back to us we did still
have to color a bunch of them because
things got lost but we started seeing on
social media people around the world
coloring these families others people
got really creative
like beautiful frames
you're noticing there's a very different
animation Styles here because we ended
up having to do five we hired and paid
young animators around the country and
around the world and then my team
um man they were amazing they had to
figure out the software for even
managing like we we should have realized
how hard it is to manage keeping track
of 15 000 frames for five films that are
being mailed around the world and you're
working remotely and your team's average
age is probably 19 and a half
um but we ended up like as this worked
spoiler
um we worked with Wu young king Kim was
the first
and she put together this beautiful and
you'll see actually she's the second I
don't even know if she knows this we
originally were talking to someone they
got sick and then we had a scramble and
someone told us about Wu young and her
work is amazing I'm gonna show you hers
then it became really obvious that we
needed help
um and animator Scott Cook from Disney
was helping also and he was helping me
figure out the flow and what software I
needed in databases and he created one
um himself and then we found Vanessa
femier who decided that the song that
the guys that put together really
reminded her of like who are the helpers
so she went off in her Direction
um all these people I sold them I needed
a three and a half minute animation and
then they had about two weeks it turns
out that's not a reasonable timeline and
they're all incredible
um Megan Kim jumps on as well she's in
LA
and we decided we were going to launch
this for Yuri's night
um so we needed to do something like
weird and Spacey
um so we also had a giant praxinoscope
built and 3 200 at the front 2500 I
forget of the frames we're actually on
postcards that eventually went to space
with blue origin but also were then
filmed in a praxinoscope
um because why not at this point
and okay we got we got we got the videos
oh that's videos we've got the frames
what do we do now
um well we need music and we could have
used the guy's music or we could have
used the sheet music and set it around
the world and asked people to do parts
that would be too easy and why why do
that at this point
um so instead what the team did is
amazing music education and composition
students music composition students on
my team they took the song broke it into
components and beats and lead sheets and
different voice parts and they posted on
the web and said hey if you want to like
make music with whatever you think you
can make music with to one of these and
then like send it to us we'll do
something with it like what can go wrong
um
over 400 music submissions came in from
around the world and we wanted to make
it easy for people because again this is
2020. so we said video sound file you
name it again I'm like thankful to our
legal team at the University because you
can imagine all the permissions I'm
meeting at this point and we all started
started noticing that these videos
coming in were incredible like we're
just gonna use the sound but like we
have videos that are just we have
hurdy-gurdy we've got you know kids who
are making art with it we have tap
dancers doing the percussion parts so
what can we do with this well
you pull together a team the director
who had been working with our team from
the beginning director Jeff Shelton
who's a long behind the scenes person
for okay go if you've watched their
behind the scenes videos Jeff probably
directed them
um Jeff actually says let's use the
videos so the ones that have videos
let's find a way to create
a virtual choir on a stage if you watch
this version there's a there's a there's
a nice twist at the end that took some
covid planning
um but Jeff worked on this one now and
I've talked to quite a few of you over
the last 24 hours and events in this
morning a lot of people here are into
music so imagine this for a second
sonically you've been you've sent things
out and told people around the world to
send in like whatever they want like
hurdy Gertie banging on the table go for
it
um how do you make that make sense for
sound
uh and how do you then string it into a
cohesive video without faking it
um
I'm just gonna let him say it this is
our music producer who is incredible
um and he's going to say these words
[Music]
so he took every single like of our team
I had a team of students education
Majors who looked at every incoming
piece and labeled like which part of the
song are they doing what instrument like
what octave maybe maybe something about
like
not skill but like you know how what's
the Chamber of that like how do we make
this into something you want to listen
to
um and you can imagine even if you just
piece the parts together it doesn't
become
music yet this is Luke's first passing
it and it he included everything that
was sent
[Music]
all right
foreign
it would have been pretty cool we could
have stopped there one music video One
song
um but again not really the style of any
of the folks involved in this project
um so if you go on Spotify and go to
okay go say I'm actually finally end up
doing five versions of this song and
Luke is a wizard and he invited everyone
to play but then he turned these into
songs so one you're gonna hear
um I'll play this at the end but then
you know what does it look like if we
got all these string instruments like
this could be an orchestra and the
lyrics are great so what if we
invited maybe you'll recognize the voice
like what kind of like voice could we
use to start this off and we ended up
with this one oops
[Music]
so the author Neil Gaiman should shift
in a vocal hair
[Music]
but then we were able to use
this choir none of these kids are in the
same room or a country
and we even found a young vocalist in
Boston
The Pianist is in New Jersey
right and then you know what happens if
we are like let's go techno let's bring
in some college students who do
electronic music and some beatbox kid
hosts
or you need a third version so we
actually ended up getting a five
um and the magic thing to me if you
don't know anything about music is that
we didn't have the song to start with
Luke had a framework and then hope the
pieces would come in
to make that work into something
so
I'd encourage you to go check out the
music we're pretty proud of them
there's something else if you think back
to when you were a kid
hopefully even to this day but when you
were a kid you might have picked people
to play with and sometimes you pick the
kid to play with who has the best toys
has anyone done that remember I'm the
kid who didn't have internet that's why
I had to like read all the MIT stuff and
not know that people are upset about it
um I had friends with the internet we
had like the video games but finding the
kid with the good toys doesn't really
last right I was joking well in an
industry in Academia we often talk about
collaboration and sometimes it means
like I ran into a problem and that
person has the software that I need and
so we collaborated like no they fixed
your problem
um
real collaboration is like you're in
this together and if you if I think back
to the best play experiences I had it
wasn't because someone had the cool toys
it was like I like being around that
person
um so a key thing is you really want to
who do you choose to play with
and that butterflies to so many things
and this is another one of those like
she couldn't have planned this if she
tried
um Luke tolger was actually the linchpin
on that project he was also one of the
most important people on code and chords
I didn't meet Luke recently actually I
met Luke when I was 10. and he was my
friend then like we used to play about
stuff and then went our different ways
he became a musician
I went off and became an engineer but
like ironically now we're in our 40s as
parents and we're doing projects
together still right because plays about
process not about the outcome some of
our stuff doesn't work but we still know
that we enjoyed the process we liked
being with each other and working on it
there's joy even when it's hard even
when we're in the middle of a pandemic
play involves freedom of choice
it wouldn't have been playful to me if
we had totally assigned in advance how
we were gonna do this music video it
could have been artistically stunning we
could have we could have cast and
assigned everything but we only did that
when we needed like a vocal here or
something everything else was what we
got and we used everything that we got
we didn't use every video but we used
the audio from every video
so as we go into the end here my my lab
also has three rules and I have this
hunch if you ask the over 100 students
who've worked in my lab over the years
to list the four elements of play I hope
that they would tell you Joy Whimsy new
people and surprise but I wouldn't bet a
lot of money on it like some of them are
gonna forget it that wasn't what they
did but there are three things that
every student in my lab I would bet this
right now could tell you what the three
lab rules are
right we put these on everything like we
have some meetings talking about like
what does this mean in a software
context what does this mean you know
working at the Children's Museum context
be kind like you don't know what people
are dealing with
um right I'm being really honest in this
talk and showing you the true flow of
things but if I gave this talk 10 years
ago it'd be a very different place like
I am here because I had mentors who
believed in me I've got a really awesome
partner and a really good therapist
because if you're constantly convinced
you're the worst person in the room in
every topic you do you start to really
doubt that and maybe I am the worst
person in the room the things I do but
I've managed to pull them together in a
new way but be kind because you don't
know what everyone's dealing with play
well with others we could talk for hours
the last one clean up your messes is a
big one that might mean literally clean
up the art supplies in the preschool
when you're done that might mean there's
pain on the wall like how do we get off
but really it also might mean this
project did not work the way we wanted
to do we didn't live up to what the
partner wanted or we we made mistakes
how do we apologize how do we accept
that you can't do something new and know
how it's going to end you just can't
right like that means you already know
the whole path and if we're about
process not outcome
you're going to spend a lot of time
apologizing and you'll learn how to do
that you learn how to figure out like
how do I build the safety net under the
trapeze even if we're flying without
safety lines I want to net there and how
do we build those Nets and we spend a
lot of time preemptively thinking about
what are the methods we're going to run
into by doing new things and if you
don't want to do if you don't want to
clean up messes you probably shouldn't
do new things
right so back to the title of this talk
you know playing with engineering I was
trying to tell you about play in
engineering and I realized in many ways
maybe what I've been doing my entire
life is playing with engineering if I
couldn't be the typical engineer like
what does it mean so what does the kid
who
talk about process not outcome I don't
know what I'm doing here like why am I
why am I in the snow on my tricycle on
the grass not the street but like
what's the worst that can happen in this
case not a lot
um and I'm sure I had a blast that day
you know how do I create an engineering
and an education culture that like my my
two kids then years ago but like that
they could be part of regardless of
their interests
how do we create you know ways of doing
these big huge projects such that even
though there's chaos around us my team
knows they have each other they still
have their Playmates right they still
have the people that they can laugh with
one of my favorite moments from this
project which from a scheduling
standpoint should have been a nightmare
was that
we found out that the verdict of the
George Floyd trial was going to come the
week that my team is on campus working
on this and someone got word of that and
the next thing I had an email and they
said Anne-Marie
um just FYI we shut down the lab because
some people were in person everyone at
home we decided that's what we should do
because we don't know how things are
going to go we'll pick it up tomorrow
and then a 19 year old knew to do that
without even checking with me first like
even though we had a deadline like
that's playing well with others
so I want to end on a music video what
does it look like when you jump in and
ask the world to collaborate
um it could look like this Andy Tim Dan
you guys ready yep yep
all right and you're rolling Maggie yep
you guys gonna actually do the pages now
right yep
here we go
in the first few weeks of the pandemic
okay go wrote and recorded a song
together alone in our homes
a few months later a high school choir
from Long Island asked for the sheet
music so they could collaborate from
their homes the same way we love that
idea I invited the world to join the
video you're about to see is one of six
new pieces made by more than 15 000
musicians artists and students from 35
States and 21 countries
[Music]
thank you
everything's untouched but forever
changed
[Music]
we painted yesterday
they look so different now
[Music]
all sounds so different somehow
everyone there is
[Music]
[Applause]
together in the chrysalis
[Music]
[Applause]
new man
[Music]
together now and everyone alone together
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
alone
so I'll end there thank you all so much
for inviting me here I really have heard
about this conference for years and have
been nervous for like months but I hope
you have an incredibly playful couple of
days
thank you
[Applause]